اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه عسكريين
بينهم ضابطان في معارك الليله الماضيه
بوسط وجنوب قطاع غزه وبذلك يرتفع عدد قتلى
الجيش الاسرائيلي المعلن منذ بدء العمليه
البريه في غزه الى
173 كما يرتفع العدد الاجمالي المعلن
لقتلاهم
معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد اخر ما تقوله اسرائيل عن
حصيله قتلاها في هذه الحرب وايضا التفاعل
مع هذا
الموضوع في ال 24 ساعه الاخيره اعترف
الجيش الاسرائيلي بمقتل سته من جنوده
وضباطه بينهم ثلاثه اعلن عنهم صباح هذا
اليوم وهم ضابطان وجندي وقد قتلوا في
معارك في مناطق جنوب قطاع غزه والمقصود
بها محيط مدينه خانيونس وداخلها ووسط قطاع
غزه وهي المحافظه الوسطى منطقه النصيرات
والمغازي والبريج وسط قطاع غزه بالاضافه
الى انه يوم امس كان قد اعترف ايضا بان
اكثر من 20 جنديا اخر قد نقلوا الى
المستشفيات في القدس وايضا في بئر السبع
هذا العدد المتواصل من سقوط الجنود
الاسرائيليين يشير الى ان المعارك ضاريه
وهو ما اقر به المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيانه الاخير الليله
الماضيه عندما قال بانه تم تعزيز القوات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه خانيونس بلواء جديد
وهذا التعزيز ياتي على خلفيه القتال
الضاري المتواصل فوق الارض وتحتها على حد
تعبيره وانه يرى في منطقه خانيونس على وجه
الخصوص بان المعقل الاساسي لكتائب القسام
لكوادرها وقيادتها وان المعارك فيها ضاريه
على نحو لافت لكن المعارك ايضا ووفق
الاسرائيليين انفسهم متواصله ايضا في
شمالي قطاع غزه ويصفون ما يجري هناك بانه
تحول الى حرب عصابات بحيث ان هناك مجموعات
او
خلايا في بعض الاحيان من مقاوم واحد او
اثنين او ثلاثه على اكبر تقدير والتي تقوم
بالانقضاض واطلاق النيران وايقاع اصابات
في صفوف القوات الاسرائيليه والتي تقول
بانها اوشكت على اتمام احتلالها لشمال
قطاع غزه بالكامل مع العلم انها ما زالت
تقصف بين الحين والاخر ومن الجو بلدات
ومدن مثل بيت لهيا وبيت حنون وهي في اقصى
الشمال وكانت اول المناطق التي كان بدا
الجيش الاسرائيلي اجتياحها واحتلالها في
ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي هذا الموضوع كان
مدرجا في الجلسه اليوميه لمجلس الح الحرب
الاسرائيلي الذي اجتمع الليله الماضيه
لتدارس استمرار هذه الحرب بعد ان تم
تفويضه رسميا من مجلس الوزاري المصغر
للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه المعروف
بالكابينه والذي مخول رسميا وفق القانون
بهذه الامور فوض مجلس الحرب باتخاذ
القرارات وياتي ذلك على خلفيه خلافات
داخله وايضا مع الولايات المتحده حول
اليوم التالي لهذه الح
وهو وهو وهو وهو وهو ما يثير خلافا مع
الولايات المتحده وداخل مجلس الحرب بحيث
ان هناك خلاف بين جانس وايزن كوت من جهه
ونتنياهو من الجهه الثانيه والقيادات
العسكريه ايضا التي تضغط على نتنياهو من
اجل بحث اجندته
وجدوله لما سيكون عليه الحال في قطاع غزه
بعد انتهاء هذا الحرب لكن الاهم انه
بشكل خاص حول
مساله ترتيب العمليات للانتقال للمرحله
الثالثه من هذه الحرب والتي متوقع ان تكون
في نهايه الاسبوع الاول من الشهر المقبل